Envie d'une réponse conjointe aux défis sécuritaires et
faire bloc contre toute agression
des États respectifs,
le Mali,
le Burkina Faso et les nigers se donnent la main
à travers 1 traité dénommé la charte du lipe taco
gourmand. Avec cette charte,
les 3 pays instituent
entre elles l'alliance des pays du Sahel AES.
L'information a été donnée cet après-midi
lors d'un point de presse
animé par le ministre malien des affaires étrangères,
Abdoulaye jobs,
en présence de ses homologues nigériens,
Burkinabé. Le connaissage de Camara,
ministre Malien La Défense était aussi de la partie.
Le point de presse dont voici la teneur,
charte de lip taco gourmand
instituant l'alliance des États du Sahel
entre le Burkina Faso,
la République du Mali
et la République du Niger,
le gouvernement de Burkina Faso,
le gouvernement de la République du Mali,
le gouvernement de la République du Niger
si après de nommée partie contractante,
réaffirmant
leur attachement à la légalité internationale
et régionale
consacrée notamment par la charte des Nations Unies,
l'acte consécutif de l'Union africaine
et le traité révisé de la CEDEAO,
convaincu
de la nécessité de poursuivre les luttes héroïques
mené par les peuples et les pays africains
pour l'indépendance politique,
la dignité humaine
et l'émancipation économique,
fidèle aux objectifs et idéaux
de l'autorité de développement intégré
des États du liptako gourmand,
guidés par l'esprit de fraternité,
de solidarité et d'amitié,
engagés à renforcer les liens séculaires
entrent leur peuple,
déterminer à exercer pleinement
et à veiller
au respect de la souveraineté nationale
et internationale.
Résolu à défendre l'unité nationale
et l'intégrité des États respectifs,
considérant les menaces
multiformes en espace commun aux 3 pays,
conscient
de la responsabilité de protéger les populations
civiles en toutes circonstances,
rappelant
le droit naturel des États à la légitime défense
individuelle ou collective,
sont convenus de ceux qui suit,
article 1ère pas de la présente Chartres,
dénommé charte du liptacot gourmand,
les parties contractantes institutent entre elles
l'alliance des États du Sahel, en abrégé a E S.
Article 2, l'objectif visé par la charte est d'établir
1 architecture de défense collective
et d'assistance mutuelle aux parties contractantes.
Article 3, les parties contractantes mettront en place
ultérieurement les organes nécessaires
au fonctionnement et mécanismes suséquents
de l'alliance
et définiront les modalités de son fonctionnement.
Article 4, les parties contractantes
s'engagent
à lutter contre le terrorisme sous toutes ses formes
et la criminalité en bande organisée
dans l'espace commun de l'alliance.
Article 5, les parties contractantes œuvreront en outre
à la prévention,
la gestion et au règlement de toutes rébellions, armées
ou autres menaces
portant atteinte à l'intégrité du territoire
et à la souveraineté
de chacun des pays membres de l'alliance
en privilégiant
les voies pacifiques et diplomatiques
et, en cas de nécessité,
à user de la force
pour faire face aux situations de rupture
de la paix et de la stabilité.
Article 6, toute atteinte à la souveraineté
et à l'intégrité territoriale
d'une ou plusieurs parties contractantes
sera considéré
comme 1 agression
contre les autres parties
et engagera 1, Devoir d'assistance et de secours
de toutes les parties
de manière individuelle
ou collective,
y compris l'emploi de la force armée
pour rétablir et assurer la sécurité
au sein de l'espace couvert par l'alliance.
Article 7, l'agression telle que évoquer à l'article 6,
comprend également toute attaque
contre les forces de défense et de sécurité
de l'une ou plusieurs parties contractantes,
y compris,
lorsque celles-ci sont déployées à titre national,
sur 1 théâtre d'opérations
en dehors de l'espace de l'alliance,
toute attaque
et en tout lieu,
contre les navires et aéronefs
de lune ou plusieurs parties.
Article 8, les parties s'engagent à
ne pas recourir entre elles à la menace,
à l'emploi de la force ou à l'agression,
soit contre l'intégrité territoriale
ou l'indépendance politique d'une partie,
à ne pas faire de blocus des ports, des routes,
des côtes ou des infrastructures
stratégiques d'une partie par les forces armées,
ne pas, à partir d'un territoire
mis à la disposition par 1 partie,
perpétrer des attaques ou des agressions
contre 1 autre partie ou des étagères,
ne pas, à partir du du territoire d'une partie,
permettre à des groupes armés,
des forces armées irrégulières ou des mercenaires
perpétrés des attaques
contre 1 pays du champ.
Article 9, les décisions de l'alliance
sont prises à l'unanimité des États partis.
Article 10, le financement de l'alliance est assuré
par les contributions des États partis.
Article 11, la présente charte peut être ouvert
à tout autre état
partageant les mêmes réalités
géographiques,
politique, socio-culturelle.
Qui accepte les objectifs de l'alliance.
La demande d'adhésion est acceptée
à l'unanimité des États partis.
Article 12, toute proposition
de modification de la présente charte
est soumise à l'acceptation unanime des États partis.
La demande de modification doit être notifiée
aux autres États partis
par la voie diplomatique
moyennant 1 préavis de 3 mois.
Article 13, tous différents
nés de l'interprétation
ou de l'application de la présente chart
est réglée par la voie diplomatique.
Article 14, la présente charte
peut être dénoncée par toute partie contractante.
La dénonciation doit être notifiée par son notaire
à toutes les parties signataires de la charte
par lettre transmise par voie diplomatique
avec accusés de réception
et 1 préavis de 6 mois.
Article 15, la présente Chartres sera complétée
par des textes additionnels
en vue de la mise en œuvre des dispositions prévues
à l'article 3.
Article 16,
les parties acceptent les termes de la présence charte
qui entre en vigueur
dès sa signature
par toutes les parties.
Article 17, la République du Mali,
désigné dépositaire de la présente charte,
transmet les copies certifiées aux autres États partis.
Le dépositaire reçoit
et soumet à la décision unanime des États partis
toute nouvelle demande d'adhésion à l'alliance
conformément aux dispositions prévues à l'article 11
de la présente charte,
fait ce jour
16/09 deux-mille-vingt-trois, pour le Burkina Faso,
le président de la transition,
chef de l'état, le capitaine Ibrahim Traoré,
pour la République du Mali,
le président de la transition,
chef de l'état,
le colonel Assimi Goïta
pour la République du Niger,
le président du conseil national
pour la sauvegarde la patrie,
chef de l'état,
le général abdoirman tchani,
en attendant la mise en place des
organes de fonctionnement,
l'achat du Luke taco gourmand vient de voir le jour.
1 message fort du Mali,
du Niger, du Burkina Faso
qui sont plus que jamais résolus
à conjuguer leur effort pour faire face aux défis.
Comment
nous en serons 1 peu plus dans les jours à venir ?